Every single stereotype that was applied in the past toward poor, low status,
blacks was overnight by these same people applied to poor, low status whites.
You go back and watch that clip and those access they did do.
And those voices hold those lines of that book learning. They are one sec,
they're 60 years away from saying the N word about the same kind of population.
It's a status thing.
And racism and classism have always been very hand in hand in this country
For a long time. The corporate press has been very good at using persuasion.
And now that the, you know,
animus toward them is at all time highs and hopefully will keep escalating their
mask is dropping and they're demonstrating. They're perfectly comfortable, uh,
using their B move, which is force if necessary. Do you think they think.
They're getting away with it?
So a great example of this would be just what happened to Joe Rogan in the last
little bit. So Rogan basically endorsed Bernie,
but he put not even quite right for him. He said, right? So he was,
so everyone was saying it was an endorsement, but it was basically like,
I liked the guy he's been consistent over the years. Something like that.
And CNN from CNN's main verified Twitter account literally
said something to the effect of Bernie Sanders under heat,
because he takes the endorsement of homophobic, racist,
Islamophobic comedian, Joe Rogan. And it's like, know,
you don't have to love Rogan. And I get it.
He's been included on scary charts that you and I have been included on.
You know, these charts they're out there.
Sometimes they put little lines next to each other and then it's like,
Oh my God, but that's not a conspiracy theory. Right. That's not. Yeah.
You're right. Exactly. Exactly. And then, yeah. All right.
We'll put that aside for a sec. Um, but when you see that it's like, Ooh,
they're they got almost nothing left. Yeah.
This is the tactic of theirs that I've called out.
I have a master threat on Twitter. It's called as an aside. So for example,
if I was describing you as someone who is an objective,
even bias let's suppose I have a biased journalist and I don't like you. Yeah.
I would still say Dave Rubin comma, who was a popular podcast or comma said,
blah, blah, blah. Right? That's an accurate framing. Yeah.
Their first sentence is always to ascribe the most nefarious framing
possible to this person. So the reader rara hold on,
Rita right away knows this is someone to avoid Joe Rogan,
comma who has a history of making homophobic and racist jokes. Comma.
If you had to describe Joe Rogan, look at this Wikipedia.
That's not what he's known as MMA comedian podcaster.
No one would define him that way,
unless you are telling and training your audience,
what to think it's completely disingenuous.
And that's the difference between having a bias and having an agenda.
If it was a bias, they said, Joe Rogan, Poplar, cat has, however,
he's gotten controversy for this. You show both sides.
That's not what they're doing. They're telling you front and center.
This person is the enemy and you should shun him. And what's beautiful is,
uh,
look who the corporate press has needlessly alienated through their chicanery
Rogan fans, Tulsi fans, Bernie fans, Andrew Yang, fans, Trump fans, Coby fans,
Don Imus fans. It's they can't help themselves. Because again,
when you have a fundamentalist faith,
you are certain that you're on the side of the angels.
That is a tough one to fight, huh? Fine mess for us.
It's easy because they're delusional, not touch with reality. So as if you,
if there's an asymmetry between truth and lies, right?
If I tell you a hundred truths and one lie,
you're going to look at me as a liar.
If I kill one person and never kill anyone else, I'm still a murderer. Right?
So if I'm presenting myself as an objective news organization,
and I'm caught once, twice, 12 times,
the average person who doesn't have any political persuasion,
one or another will not look at me as trustworthy. And once trust is lost,
it is almost impossible to be regained.
So with that in mind, let's talk about this clip that went viral, the CNN, uh,
it's Don lemon, uh, who's their main anchor.
Don Don used to be a friend of mine. He was on this show.
I'm not here to throw the guy under the bus.
Don lemon comma, who used to be.
Yeah, exactly. Who must be on a chart with Dave Rubin? Um,
and it was Rick Wilson, who is a,
is he a Republican strategist supposedly? Right? I mean,
that's what it says under his name. And the other person was.
For Reed. I forget his name. And I'm going to sound racist if I try. All right.
So we were right. And some other guy, but it's three of them.
They've got their heads in boxes on CNN.
And can you just describe what happened? And then the reaction,
it's such a perfect example of all of this.
There was a lot to unpack in this clip.
So Rick Wilson was making the joke that Trump is so dumb that he couldn't find
Ukraine on a map, right? This is, you know, one-on-one humor.
Right? And Don lemon, it was.
There's this, there's this mental,
there's this condition called Angelman syndrome. And when kids have it,
they can't help but laugh all the time.
And it's kind of disturbing because there'll be in their crib, just cracking up.
And he just loses it as if it's the funniest thing he's ever heard.
And I'm like, this is first grade playground stuff. It's not clever.
And they start going off on how all these Trump voters are like, Oh,
you guys are elitist with your geography and your lines on the map. It all felt.
Extremely produced. Like, do you think that was spontaneous?
I think it was very spontaneous riffing off each other. Here's my point.
There's something I talk about in the book called nitwits and tell me why you
think it's not that not spontaneous.
Because the way they were riffing off each other,
these people don't riff off each other. Well, like when you see,
when you see lemon and Cuomo do it, it's horrible.
It's so stilted. You can tell these people don't really like each other.
They have this awkward minute between their shows when they do it.
And also I know a lot of these people, like, you know,
a lot of people like the way they are and their ability to be human on camera.
It's not like this. It literally, it's not like this,
what we're doing right now where it's like, we have cameras on us,
but we're acting basically the same, you know,
there's always like you turn the camera on. What's that, what's that theory,
you know, there's that,
there's a name for that theory when you turn the camera on. Oh, I don't know.
I can't remember what it's called, but,
but we're basically acting like ourselves and there's nothing suddenly that this
camera goes off, that I'm going to, our interaction would be wildly different.
Right. We went out to dinner a couple weeks ago, is this right? As I said,
it began the show. This is how I dress up.
This is exactly what you were wearing. You were wearing the Tulsi,
the last slot that tells the appropriate. Right, right, right.
I keep forgetting.
But so it struck me as the level that Don was laughing did not
strike me as uncontrollable after he'd struck me as uncontrollably,
fake laughter. Interesting.
And the way that they were all bouncing back and forth was like,
they had planned this. Like they need something to go viral. Like,
I don't know you,
you might be writing and maybe it's somewhere in between what we're both saying.
Both theories are so stupid. It's hard to figure out which sports reality.
Right. I'm hearing what you're saying. And it's completely plausible.
They sat down and did like the worst improv class in history.
But there's a couple of things in that clip that I thought are very cogent.
There's this concept called Midwest. That is, I've mentioned my book,
which is about people who are marginally intelligent, right.
When you're barely smarter than average,
but you have debt are desperate to demonstrate your brilliance, right?
Because there's very few chances where you're going to be the smart one.
If you're six foot, you are tall, you're above average.
But when are you going to be the tall guy? Never.
So to think that being able to find Ukraine who everyone who's played
risk can find,
it can be found on a map as a sign of your brilliance speaks to your
intelligence. And the other point is Jim goad,
the writer who wrote the redneck manifesto,
he made the point that every single stereotype that was applied in the past
toward poor, low status,
blacks was overnight by these same people applied to poor, low status whites.
You go back and watch that clip and those access they did do. And those voices,
those lines in that book learning, they are one sec,
they're 60 years away from saying the N word about the same kind of population.
It's, it's a status thing.
And racism and classism have always been very hand-in-hand.
And in this country. So then what is going on in their minds,
in a segment like that,
do they honestly think that they are helping whatever the cause is? Right?
I think this is what I think. I think now they are in retreat.
I think they get a lot of heat on social media where people call them out on
their map, malfeasance and depravity, and they're getting defensive.
And now they are being sarcastic because sarcasm is often a sign of cognitive
incident dissonance,
where your brain has to contradict your ideas and can't reconcile them.
So for them, the idea that maybe I always tweeted this, that these people, I go,
have you ever wondered if maybe you're one of the bad guys, uh,
the idea that we're not better than everyone else,
that we're not particularly bright. It's true,
but it's very disturbing to their self image because, Hey, I'm on CNN,
I'm on a panel clearly. I'm brilliant. And no, Anna Navarro is on this.
She's not brilliant. She's William Howard Taft.
Is also called me racist on Twitter. So, you know, comma. Yeah.
Who's called Dave and racist comma. Um,
who sat down with Michael malice who was, you know, Tulsi, Gabbard,
appropriated the comma. Okay. Um, it reminds me of, um,
something that happened be about a year ago, a good friend of mine,
who I went to. I grew up with, I went to college with,
we both studied political science together. We've been friends for, you know,
our whole lives or, you know, 40 some odd years. Um, he's a huge lefty now.
Obviously we diverged politically. Uh,
but we went out for a drink and we sorta got into it and he was getting very
heated and I just kept trying to get out of politics.
I tried and I'm sure you've been in a million of these where you just,
you try to let it go. And there's something that's beyond politics.
And I was trying to talk about his kids and everything else going on and he
couldn't get there. And I finally said to him, I said,
do you think that I believe what I believe as much as you believe what you
believe in great question. And without pausing with no hesitation, he said no.
And I thought, and then, yeah, and this is a really willing,
this is a really rare moment for me. It, then it then really escalated.
And I've never done this before. I swear to you. I've never done this before.
I've never done this before I threw money down. I paid for the whole thing,
the whole tab right there. And I walked out.
I've never done anything like that before.
And it's so counter to write everything you know about me,
but I thought that moment right there,
like you have to sit in that now the like I'm not attacking your motives,
but you actually believe that. I can't believe what I proport.
What's amazing is there is a continuum and there's lots of people who would
blurt that out. And as soon as they heard themselves say it, they'd be like,
Whoa, Whoa. Oh, okay. I've gone down the wrong path.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop, yelling out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.